all right it's time for a mid-year list
of my favorite songs and albums of the
year so far
i'm going to present these in
alphabetical order let's start with
songs first we have from bo burnham that
funny feeling
next up if you saw my q a video you knew
this was coming it's cassandra jenkins
hard drive
the mind is just a hard drive
next we have a song from hiatus coyote i
had a hard time picking a favorite on
this album but for now i'm going to go
with red room
it feels like i'm inside a flash
song that deserves more love uh internet
money and don tolliver's his and hers
featuring gunna and lil uzi vert
[Music]
coming in next is lucy dakis too many
good songs in this album
but for now thumbs i would
kill him here's what i'm sure you didn't
see coming
it's miley cyrus's cover of fade into
you by mazzy starr
next up you gotta do it olivia rodrigo
good for you
[Music]
and now for a song on everybody in their
mother's list it's leave the door open
by silk sonic
next we've got a song that continues to
blow me away it's tyler the creator's
will sure
i met you on a saturday knew it was
something as soon as you spoke it out
last on the list from your old drew we
have the magic watch
all right time for albums again
alphabetical here and we have to kick it
off with the one
that made them sound famous and the one
that made me famous it's
brockhampton with roadrunner new
lightning machine
[Music]
next up is one of my favorite rap albums
right now it's bruiser wolf's dope game
stupid
revenge is a sport payback as a mother
you're gonna pay for it here's one that
held my top spot for a long time
cassandra jenkins an overview
on phenomenal nature
i'm not sure if it'll make the year
endless but uh zarface and mf doom
super what soul surviving
never stop this one should come as no
surprise it's
hiatus coyote with mood valiant
[Music]
and somehow in the same week we got home
video from lucy dakis i mean come on
next on the list from the enigmatic
makhami we have pray for haiti
i've seen conflicting sources on how to
pronounce this but
do moktar is a freak team
next up on the list we have slater with
troubled paradise
last alphabetically but maybe first
preference wise is tyler the creator
with call me if you get lost
[Music]
thanks everyone for watching i know this
was long if you'll excuse me i'm going
to go refresh
apple music until donda drops